why do you think comedy is male
dominated or does it feel male dominated
well i think the act of comedy itself is
extremely masculine thing you're walking
on stage and and you're like yeah what i
have to say is important and you guys
will respond to it like the whole thing
is extremely masculine in itself
um
yeah it's almost like a combat you're
almost going to a war in a way yeah it
feels like yeah um
in combat was stereotypically has always
been a male thing right kind of you know
yeah it's changing yeah you know but i
think like if you look at like kind of
like the
arch types or whatever then it's usually
a man out there you know yeah and i
think also
uh the the population in the country
really i mean it's also changing in this
way because of podcasting and um online
specials and social media and all this
stuff but like before i started a comedy
i was maybe aware of five comedians yeah
and they're only the top five big like
you're not really aware of the um comedy
landscape and so i don't think people
really have been exposed to that um many
female comedians and i don't like to
think about it because i don't want to
have that perspective i don't think it's
helpful for me yeah to be like no no
one's gonna you know whatever i have a
[ __ ] but um
i do notice it sometimes like online
where you'll see like youtube comments
or something and you're like oh the rest
of the country only thinks
men are funny just naturally it's just
like a misogynist thing yeah and but
also who gives a [ __ ] about them you
have your own audience whatever yeah i
think i mean well finding your own
audience is key i mean i think different
places i i think
and i don't know if it's the rest of the
country thing i don't know it's like
it always seems like i here's what i
think sometimes as when i think about
male and female comedians
i always men it always seems like
they are
and maybe this is just because i've seen
this in television and film over the
years but they're like the goofball
they're the
the [ __ ] you know they're the bat
bumbling
you know yeah i know what you mean and
so you don't mind if something happens
to the bumbling
you don't mind if that guy steps in a
fire slips on a banana peel
for me the thing that always
and this was the same thing about you
watching ufc women i didn't like it at
first i didn't like it because it felt
like i didn't think all these people
shouldn't be able to do this right i
think anybody should do whatever they
want it just was like i always thought
of women as like mom yeah exactly and
like a sister right so when you think
about oh man my sister you know it it's
a male instead of yours it's your
sister's getting in a fight that you
help or like
and then comedy i always felt like was
such an uncomfortable i think also so it
was like man this is so uncomfortable
you don't a woman doesn't need to go
through this
that's what my dad said like i should
put my if i see a woman walking on stage
i should put my coat down over like you
a
know
step in the state you know or step in
the the so i think there's a lot of that
i don't know if it's that
for me it was never that women shouldn't
do this
but i did always i think and it wasn't a
choice i made no it's an unconscious
bias like for you you're saying it's
like a certain fragility that you're
worried about that yeah i just felt like
why do we like
why do women have to do why do they need
to uh endure this
that's literally what my dad said to me
like when i first started he's like
you're one of the smartest people i've
ever met why are you choosing to put
your life in a basement with drunks and
fuck-ups
and i was like fair fair point you know
but
also it's just like it is what it is
it's like uh like my i think what you're
saying is totally real like because i
feel that way that i'm received that way
in orange county because they cannot
fathom
that a woman would not my own
focus and priority would not be to be
married with three kids right now right
and like my family's never seen me my
brothers have but my my parents have
never seen me do comedy before
wow or any of my tv stuff either well
here's something also that happens a lot
of women start doing comedy right and
i'm probably going to receive hell for
this because it's a very it's a
generalization here's something that i
sometimes feel could be realistic and i
don't know here we go um
and they and then the first thing they
do is beat this woman drum
instead of beating the comedy drum you
know it's like um
you mean off stage
yeah kind of it's like i'm a female like
somebody will be doing it a month and
they're big and they're just like i you
just start getting into like
this i'm a and i think maybe it was a
kind of a fad that happened for a while
it was like um
and maybe women needed to maybe they
need to do that to make sure that
they're seen in like a in like a
male-dominated environment you know but
i feel like sometimes uh
people will lean so much on any whatever
it is that makes them
like oh i'm southern or i'm a woman or i
was on fire you know you see some guy
and he's got skin grafts he's like i was
on fire you know that's his big thing
and he's like you know
fire shows you know we're doing
everybody who's on been on fire ever you
got to be on you know you're on the fire
lineup only yeah you know
victim you know like somebody your neck
brace line you know it's neck brace
knight at the [ __ ]
um
and i don't think that's a bad i'm not
saying it's a bad thing i don't know
what i'm saying exactly
i guess i'm saying some people attach
themselves so much to something
that they
forget that what they're doing is that
you we still have to do the thing yeah i
mean i feel two ways i'm not saying that
about you no i don't think you you've
never even seen me do comedy yeah
i wonder if that's true or not
i don't think so
uh
but yeah i
i want to be aware of [ __ ] and sometimes
i can feel things like a lot of times
when i'm in a green room i mean less now
that i'm like more known but like
immediately when you walk in a green
room if it's like a older comic or a
famous com they think that you're the
girlfriend of another dude
and it's just like but like that's not
something i'm gonna get upset about but
i can feel it immediately when i walk in
yeah it's interesting it's interesting
because i wonder yeah why do i sometimes
feel like or what are some of the things
that make me feel like it's a man sport
or that it makes i think yeah i think
those are the things for me about that
it's like there's some
fragility to it that you don't want it's
like a
i mean i don't know you well but you
seem
like
the
area of comedy that you roll in is hyper
masculine and the people that you're
friends with
yeah
i guess so yeah i mean i have some
female comedian friends you know um
[Music]
but i guess yeah i mean i guess more my
comedian friends are probably men
probably yeah i mean that makes sense
yeah or more years women you think
uh no i have like a mix i mean
i always say like i don't really like
being a woman
though the best part about being a woman
is female friendship like my
girlfriends in comedy are it's just like
the best thing in the world because
we're not really like it's such a uh
it's such a distinct
uh way of life that many people don't
understand and especially like growing
older as a woman
uh people can't really understand like
why you would want to do it so it's like
you really understand each other in a
way that other people don't so many
people have know nothing about comedy
totally you're like in the world so you
know you start to like but then there's
some people having no idea about like
they couldn't like chris wright they
would just name chris rock like yeah
eddie murphy you know
yeah they wouldn't know robin right yeah
you know um they have one point of
reference like uh a lot of my
girlfriends uh and i joke about it but
like so many people will be like and
they'll be trying to compliment you but
it's [ __ ] rude they'll be like you're
like a more funny amy schumer or like a
less funny amy schumer whatever it is
they're just comparing you and it's like
you could just say good job right
[ __ ] yeah people don't know how i mean
i think some people also they just don't
know that much you know like you're
saying if they're trying to give you
some people are bad at compliments yeah
it's always like backhanded or whatever
but it's the point is that they have one
woman and she has blonde hair right and
so they immediately they're like i have
to make that association and i have to
tell it directly to this person yeah
yeah yeah i wonder what isn't what is
that in people that makes them that
makes us feel like we have to do that
sometimes i think now things have been
changing and going in a great direction
but like the women before me
they always said like you know they
could be better than some dudes in clubs
like around the country wouldn't
headline them because they said like
people wouldn't come
you know so it's like based on like
but then who's is that anybody's fault
though or is that just business
like you it is business but it's [ __ ]
dumb because it's not based on
necessarily on talent like when you see
like lori kill martin when you watch
laurica martin she's like one of the
best joke writers in the country and she
just
murders and to think of like a mediocre
dude headlining over her is sad right
you know what i mean right but i think a
lot of that goes to like
just business it's the same as like
like you could put a ton you could lay
you could put a a a line up and
diversify it all you want right but in
the end if it doesn't sell t if people
aren't buying tickets to go see it like
if the if the people aren't buying
tickets to go see it then no the market
is dumb
right
so yeah yeah in the end it's like yeah
it just has to be so meritocracy it
doesn't always figure out i guess then
does it no meritoxy is what i mean is
just on stage where you're like right
okay we'll see who's good and who's not
oh i've seen tons of people over the
years that get opportunities because of
like nepotism
religion
um
you know like uh certain friendships
that kind of stuff just happens i think
it happens in all walks of life you know
yeah
yeah
like you see but that's also the thing
that makes you keep [ __ ] going like
if you showed up and just walked in or
like hey i'm here and i'm funny yeah
just because i'm
black female was in a fire
you know
died and came back to life i love how
you keep saying
was in a fire as if that was someone's
thing i'm just thinking different oh it
certainly is man they got all these
shows it's like i saw one one show it
was like uh
i haven't been going to these shows
you've been going to it's just some of
the things i get you know i get a link
or something hey check out this and it's
all like
um like not of not victims affliction
well it's like affliction night i said
publicly
do not ask me to do your all-female show
that it's like ladies of laughter or
some [ __ ] i'm like that is so [ __ ]
humiliating why don't you just call it
look at these clams yapping like i
cannot i mean like i cannot even fathom
that [ __ ] it's so embarrassing well here
here's so that here's something that
happens i think
a lot of men also for me i remember like
i was so it was so tough sometimes like
um
who was that talking about one time
oh nicki glaze when i first heard her
act it reminded me for some reason of my
mother specifically and so i couldn't
listen or accommodate the beginning
because there was just some weird
correlation between like her and what my
mom sounded like to me growing up right
yeah it's not that way now i mean and
she know i've taught it's just been like
a funny thing but
um
right and girls probably do the same to
guys i bet yeah well and there's also
just a thing of like you know
it's good to be able to do well in front
of everyone but there are demographics
that are going to be not more naturally
drawn to you and your material and who
you are and what you're talking about
like i don't like right which is totally
fine and that's
like the other night i did a show at
that comedy jam jam in the vans
so
and then we had a uh there was a
comedian on the lineup who's a female
comedian right she says to me then the
crowd was pretty diverse
she comes up to me after the show she
goes hey i just want to say i saw your
crowd very diverse group you're really
doing your job that's what she said to
me and i'm like i will never work with
this girl again for saying that because
like you know how hard it is to get any
audience you think i'm i have to get a
certain type of audience like that's
[ __ ]
crazy to me like i'm happy to sell any
tickets like
now i have to make sure each audience
member like this person you know has a
hat this person has glasses this
person's a ginger this person's a
filipino like that's [ __ ] impossible
yeah right like i don't know and maybe i
had like i mean i could have had like an
overreaction it just seemed like
and this was a girl who doesn't sell
tickets which is fine right
but it was like are you really telling
me like that i have to have now a diet
like a diverse audience like
it just [ __ ] was like that's
impossible
okay maybe some people it's possible but
i love that you had it and this is a
person who doesn't sell tickets yeah
hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy
two options
watch one this one or this one